Alrighty!
It is time to get started on
The Responsive Blog Project.
You can find a link to a zip
file with the project in it
in the downloadable section.
Note that the zip file is pretty large
because of all the images inside it.
So this is what the blog
looks like right now.
And you should be asking yourself,
ugh, what the heck is this ugly thing?
The good news is that, by the end of
the course, you'll be turning it into
something that looks a little bit like
this, which is definitely a lot nicer.
Now, responsive images can be as
much of an art as it is a science.
The way you make your images responsive
will totally depend on how you want to
use them in your sites.
When all is said and done, your blog
may look very different than this, but
that doesn't make it any less correct.
It's up to you to decide how you
want to beautify this blog and
make its images responsive.
To start working on this project, which
is really zoomed out here by the way,
I'm going to give you a few changes.
Some will be mandatory and
some will be optional.
Your goal is to make
these images look sane.
Right now, they're massive, both in
their visual size on the page, and
this is zoomed out to 25% here so
they're really, really big.
And they're also big in a number
of bytes that they include,
in that they're simply way too large.
Back at 100%,
it's pretty clear these images aren't
fitting inside their containers.
The images in the website need some
kind of width applied to them so
that they stay inside their container,
which in this case is an article.
Once you've done that, set a maximum
width on the article element to
give the blog a little
bit better structure.
I recommend starting with a width
of something around 50em's.
Remember an em refers to the font size.
So a 50em element with
font sizes of 16 pixels
means that we are talking
about a width of 800 pixels.
By the way, notice how these images
are coming from images source
we will come back to that in a second.
Next up, check out this Volt.
You see how its natural
width is almost 3300 pixels?
That's just massive.
What's the point of so
many pixels when it's going to be
displayed at about 800 pixels wide?
Even on a 2x display,
you only need 1600 pixels across.
So there are so many wasted bytes here.
These images need to be a lot smaller.
I want you to use the tools and
techniques that you've been learning.
To reduce the resolutions and
compress the images.
See how low you can get
the resolution you can use and
how much compression you can use while
still keeping really crisp images.
To do so, you have Grunt, Image Magick
and Image Optim on your side.
And you definitely don't have use these,
but
it will make you life a lot easier
if you do, especially Grunt.
If you've got Grunt up and running,
you should be able to use the Grunt
file in the project directory after you
run the command in the instructor notes.
The command will make sure
the grunt-responsive -images package
is installed.
Notice that Grunt is going to run
against images in the images_src/
directory.
and put them in the images directory.
Right now the html all the images can be
found in the images source directory.
But once you've optimized them,
make sure you change their
directory to images.
There are links to lots of
documentation in the instructor
notes if you need help.
Right now, the page is coming
in around 3.1 megabytes,
which will take forever
to load on mobile.
Seriously, try loading this
site using the network
throttling options set to 3G.
You may want to grab a cup of coffee
while you wait a few minutes for
the page to load.
You can probably reasonably drop the
total bytes from the images below to 1.5
megabytes or even further.
In terms of optional changes, the images
are looking pretty lonely right now.
They need some captions.
So we'll add some.
In this solution video, you'll see me
add some captions using the semantic
figure tag, but you can use
whatever technique you'd like.
See the instructor notes for
more documentation on figure.
So, to summarize, first things first,
make sure the images fit
within their containers.
Then once you've done that,
make the containers a reasonable width.
And I recommend about 50em.
Once the images are actually
being displayed properly,
it's time to resize and compress them.
They should stay sharp but the page
should drop below 1.5 megabytes total.
In fact, I'd be willing to bet you could
do even better than 1.5 megabytes.
Make sure to use automation tools.
Otherwise, your life is going to be
much more difficult than it needs to be.
But to be fair,
it can be difficult installing Grunt, so
make sure you use the instructor notes.
And as an optional challenge,
add some captions.
Of course, make sure you're testing on
different devices and network settings.
And once you've done the first,
second, and
third parts of this challenge,
a code will appear on the screen.
Type that code in here to continue.